there is a distinction to be made where
it's like sure maybe you don't cancel
you know them forever sure people can
make changes and improve and come back
we've seen that happen but the first
step towards that is embracing your
situation and removing yourself for a
while so you can do that work and heal
yeah and then come back and show that
you've done the work i feel like there's
a lot of
apology coming from people online with
little conspiracies of oh it was
provoked by this or oh the couple
dropped the restraining order because of
that but i'm like if you have to come up
with a conspiracy or or some kind of you
know out there reason to explain one
after another after another event like
this i feel like you have to look at the
subject and go maybe there's something
wrong with that person that needs to be
addressed
[Music]
ezra ezra ezra miller
you say ezra's name three times
and he ezra will show up to punch you
i'll assault
come into your hotel room in the middle
of night and take your passport dude
stop getting arrested please stop
getting arrested stop assaulting people
the more this happens the longer we have
to wait to see the flashbacks yes that's
what's truly important i will put aside
all these things about you as long as we
can sit there for two hours and watch
the flash and forget about real life and
people's we will do it millions of
people across the globe do it all right
guys let's get a little serious first
things first a lot of people were
correcting us in the comments i was not
aware of this ezra miller has
specifically chosen pronouns okay so
there's there's no more he they it's
just only they them now i believe so
okay so
this is us learning to be respectful i
can't remember my talk a little bit
slower just to make sure i'm being
respectful not to sincerely ezra miller
however to the community though as much
as there's people out there who like
object against that like who freaking
pronouns i'll i'll do my best to respect
it okay it's not that big a deal it's
not that big a deal i just got it
remember
so ezra miller was uh reportedly
arrested for a second time here's a fun
fact miller is scheduled to be in court
tuesday to enter a plea on harassment
and disorderly conduct charges that is
pertaining to ezra's first arrest now as
we've been arrested a second time if you
guys don't know of what's been happening
with ezra miller we'll journey back a
few years ago ezra choked the fan and we
never heard anything about what happened
now in hawaii ezra reportedly was
behaving violently at a bar
at someone and yell at some people
there's another report that ezra broke
into a couple's home stole some
belongings threatened them that couple
filed a restraining order dropped the
restraining order
who knows why ezra was really provoked
at the bar who knows why that couple
dropped the restraining order maybe
they're big fans of zack snyder's
justice league who knows what's
happening people are getting paid off i
don't know i don't want to spend my time
dealing with conspiracies or speculation
i'm just going to go off of the facts
that are being reported in the news and
the articles and what's being reported
is ezra's doing some [ __ ] some violent
actions and is getting in trouble albeit
seems to be pretty light for ezra miller
how ezra's getting in trouble what's
happening with the second arrest
reportedly it's for second-degree
assault comes from rolling stone per
police report during an investigation
police identified miller as the suspect
and determined that they became irate
after being asked to leave and
reportedly threw a chair
striking a 26 year old female in the
forehead resulting in an approximate
half inch cut the victim declined
medical treatment what because of a
check from the wb
this all happened at a residence
apparently in pahoa this is a serious
serious charge our days of making
excuses for ezra are done they were done
for me a while ago back with that first
sentence man they really gotta be done
now yeah this is unacceptable of course
what's the first thing that uh i do when
i hear of such i think i go online i
just want to like see oh my god how are
people responding to this and it's
exactly what happened before same exact
thing that happens every time i don't
know why this is everyone's first
concern is replace
replace esther miller with grant gustin
remember the first choice remember
what's really important here guys all
right we need that flash movie who cares
about the people who are being hurt
circumstances are one thing but we can't
stop the movie business secondly the
other thing that i see is while there's
people who are like yeah ezra ezra ought
to be fired there's this other really
big camp of people who seem so concerned
about ezra's mental health now mental
health is something i take very very
seriously i took mental health serious
before mental health was such a popular
keyword out there all right i've been in
therapy for like 10 years i take that
[ __ ] super super serious i've never been
anywhere near on the level of pressure
that i imagine someone like ezra miller
has had to deal with with these huge
profile films being in the public
spotlight whatever it may be all right
bottom line is though while i do think
ezra miller certainly has mental health
struggles i believe anyone who is
consistently caught doing this type of
behavior has mental health struggles i
don't
really
side with the whole victimizing ezra in
the public spotlight if you feel
sympathetic towards whatever struggles
ezra may have i get that i do i i
totally get it even for me i feel a
little bit bad for ezra sure just
because whatever this individual may be
going through might be extremely rough i
don't know ezra personally 99.9 percent
of the people who are very sympathetic
towards ezra don't know him personally
they probably just really like his work
a lot which fine totally fair bottom
line though i do believe a it's really
messed up how warner brothers just is so
tight-lipped about all this i think it's
really messed up they've kept amber
heard on freaking awful man dealing with
the whole ray fisher situation like
there's a whole bunch of drama that wb
deals with they love jk rowling
they seem to wait for the court of
public opinion to sway to the point
where people are so upset that they have
to act and then that's when they
actually act it's weird because ezra
gets this like superstar treatment wb
just be like just don't say anything you
stop anything like how did we need ezra
ezra it's our money maker what is
happening how did they wind up in that
position in the first place i mean
obviously some good performances some
good roles but like that is i associate
with being like superstar like you're an
institution and it's like a real big
business threat if we don't have you in
the fold kind of behavior at least from
the studio and i don't see how esther
rose to that status i think ezra miller
ought to be relieved from the projects
moving forward i i full heartily
actually believe that hey there has to
be consequences for this type of action
this whatever mental health struggles
ezra miller has that doesn't matter like
will smith for example clearly has
probably some mental health struggles
and did something pretty messed up at
the oscars and is now suffering the
consequences for that action ezra miller
should get the same exact treatment
doesn't matter if it wasn't at some big
televised event this is a consistent
pattern ezra miller should suffer some
consequences from this in order for ezra
miller for all those who really are
sympathetic towards his plight everyone
should realize that if ezra continues to
get these big jobs that is only enabling
his behavior because ezra can keep
getting away with this type of behavior
if ezra is still allowed to keep working
often times when you start to lose
something that means ah i really need to
like check myself in and start getting
some real help in order to come back in
the spot like like a robert downey jr
situation in a way there comes a point
in time where it's like you got to stop
feeling sorry for someone and start
going you need to take responsibility
for your actions and you need to do
something about it and with that comes
sacrificing some other stuff absolutely
and i mean i understand the sympathy
people want to have toward a person
clearly demonstrating some sort of
mental anguish or mental you know health
struggle and i feel like there is a
pollution of that conversation by you
know the way we all get up in arms about
who cancel culture and why people are
removed from the spotlight or not but
i've heard fame described by others as a
unique kind of trauma which you know
obviously you know a person in ezra
miller's position very blessed you know
gets to you know enjoy the finest things
in life probably but at the same time
it's a grind there's a lot you have to
put yourself through mentally and
physically and it's you know a lot more
than just showing up on set and
pretending for a few days while
necessarily it's not the same thing as
going like oh you know cancel this you
know truly malicious evil person or
something like that it's more we should
remove them from this situation so that
they can get the help they actually need
instead of being in this position where
they're prone to
being overloaded or whatever is
motivating this it's hard to be under
that big of a microscope and yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if people are
being sort of paid to contain this
situation or whatever but it keeps
happening and in such a tight cluster i
don't think you can really deny that
that's not a healthy person to have in a
workplace and every movie is a workplace
and every workplace is made up of people
trying to just do their job right and
this gets in the way of all of that and
it bleeds out into just regular life and
so yeah while i feel like some people
are like i want to take sympathy on the
guy and i don't want him to have him
canceled or something like that i feel
like there is a distinction to be made
where it's like sure maybe you don't
cancel you know them forever sure people
can make changes and improve and come
back we've seen that happen but the
first step towards that is embracing
your situation and removing yourself for
a while so that you can do that work and
heal and then come back and show that
you've done the work i feel like there's
a lot of
apology coming from people online with
little conspiracies of oh it was
provoked by this or oh the couple
dropped the restraining order because of
that but i'm like if you have to come up
with a conspiracy or or some kind of you
know out there reason to explain one
after another after another event like
this i feel like you have to look at the
subject and go maybe there's something
wrong with that person that needs to be
addressed i believe in a good comeback
story but in order for there to be a
comeback there has to be a going away
first yeah yeah don't implode on
yourself and yes have that be the going
out this is destructive behavior this
has to change and ezra shouldn't be
rewarded with millions of dollars per
film you know bottom line because that's
ridiculous in their biggest franchises
and is about to be three roles in a
pivotal movie for them which i get as a
studio is hard how do you deal with that
but it's only getting worse the less
they deal with yeah all right guys well
what do you think should ezra be let go
should we just give the wb like a little
pat on the back here what do you think
should happen nothing nothing nothing he
goes free scott yeah
just keep on keeping on fantastic piece
four
all right guys well we'll talk with you
guys soon
[Music]
you